[Musica]
[Applauso]
che strano momento
stiamo uscendo da una pandemia ci
ritroviamo una guerra qui in europa tra
capo e collo questo sta combinando le
nostre vite il nostro modo di vedere la
vita
io dovevo portare questo telex qui nel
2020 e invece sono qua nel 2022
dovevo parlare del mercato senza denaro
e del mercato con il denaro
nel frattempo però sono successe le cose
che hanno confermato questa mia proposta
sto parlando di fenomeni sociali
abbastanza importanti in particolare
negli stati uniti sta succedendo una
cosa che viene chiamata come i big quid
sta arrivando anche in italia 21 milioni
di americani hanno lasciato il posto di
lavoro lasciare il posto di lavoro
significa non essere licenziati ma
decidere di abbandonare quel lavoro un
po di sicurezza che avevano allora i
sociologi stavo spiegando questo
fenomeno è stato dicendo che in realtà
quello che stiamo facendo noi stiamo
andando a rivalutare il bilanciamento
tra la vita lavorativa il mercato con il
denaro è la vita invece personale che il
mercato senza denaro
ora per spiegare questi concetti devo
fare una premessa la premessa che faccio
è che la nostra cultura ha
contrabbandato il concetto che il
successo fosse uguale al denaro cioè una
persona che ha denaro a successo una
persona che è successo a denaro
ammetto lo creduto pure io ci ho creduto
anch'io colpevolmente oggi che la barba
bianca e un po di cicatrici sulle spalle
o un altro concetto invece io ho capito
anche nel mondo lavorativo che non è la
persona che allo stipendio più alto non
è successo ma è una persona che fa
quello che fa con passione e la passione
che rende di successo la persona
indipendentemente da quello che guadagno
ora mi devo presentare perché così si
capisce comuni non è la propria strada
quali stata la mia strada mi ha portato
a questo pensiero io sono nato in un
piccolo paesino a il centro della
sardegna san barbato zero è un paesino e
si chiama laconi molto carino
poi ho studiato e in ingegneria mi sono
laureato con lode in una università del
nord a trieste
mi sono trasferito in veneto e in veneto
preso un master in business
administration in una delle più rinomate
scuole di business che ci sono qui nel
veneto per guardone soltanto domani in
tutta italia
quindi ha aggiunto a questa parte più
tecnica una parte un po più umanistica e
quindi ho approcciato al coaching e oggi
ho
un sogno che è quello di laurea in
sociologia aveva ricominciato a dieci
giorni fa perché fatto il toy che sembra
anche con buon voto quindi probabilmente
mi sono già prescritto quindi partirò
per realizzare questo sogno questo tutto
questo è il mercato senza denaro di
claudio perché qui non abbiamo parlato
di denaro qui stiamo parlando invece
soltanto di quelle che sono state le mie
scelte e come mi hanno trasformato e
chiaro che però il mercato col denaro è
incalzante c'è anche qui è infatti nella
stessa strada intervalli troviamo che
dopo la laurea ingegneria cosa ho fatto
ho incominciato a lavorare in una
multinazionale tedesca
successivamente sono passato in una
piccola media azienda italiana questo
prima del masters dopo il master sono
invece mi sono spostato e suonati una
multinazionale in svizzera
chiaramente sempre per posizioni apicali
dopodichè sono nato in una piccola media
azienda veneta che ho nel cuore
sono persone meravigliose
ho visto anche qualche socio quanto è lì
c'era un passaggio generale in corso e
questo momento questa esperienza mi ha
aiutato a maturare una convenzione
addirittura ho creato io ho aperto la
mia azienda che aiuta le piccole e medie
aziende italiane a fare il passaggio
generazionale
ok questo stesso l'azienda poi la
utilizzo perché siccome credo dei
ragazzi e nelle startup la utilizzo
funzionalmente come business angel ecco
questo è un po il film della mia vita no
come e qui siamo a lei che movie è lei
che movie mi ha fatto riflettere sul
ruolo che noi ci diamo oppure a qualcun
altro ci dà e come questi ruoli siano o
meno in sintonia con la nostra vita
siccome volevo parlare del mercato re
del mercato senza denaro ed a fano nel
2020 faccio un po fu un passaggio dai
che movie abbiamo dei figli film di
fantascienza successa quasi sempre la
macchina del tempo entriamo nella
macchina del tempo e adesso ci troviamo
nel 2020 cosa volevo raccontarvi le boe
nuovo raccontare che esiste un mercato
il denaro ma attenzione questo qua lo
conosciamo tutti perché sono le aziende
e le aziende cosa fanno le aziende
hanno delle risorse usano i soldi per
coprire risorse perché è un prodotto
servizio che vendono immettono sul
mercato per poterlo poi quindi vendere è
soddisfare il bisogno di denaro col
fatturato quando ricevono questo denaro
fanno il passaggio successivo cioè ed
investono questo denaro per altre
risorse perché altri prodotti per
mettere in circolo nel mercato col
denaro
e chiaro che hanno un unico obiettivo
l'unico obiettivo dell'azienda è quello
di chiudere il bilancio in positivo
punto poi c'è anche il mercato senza
denaro e questo già un pochino più
nascosto
anche qui ci sono risorse ma le risorse
ci sono tutte risorse di prima ma non
c'è il tempo non c'è il denaro
c'è il tempo ad esempio le competenze
allora quando noi mettiamo insieme tutte
queste cose creiamo un prodotto servizio
e questo prodotto servizio siamo noi e
quando ci siamo rigenerati cosa facciamo
ci scambiamo anzi scambiamo emozioni
perché dobbiamo soddisfare dei bisogni
che possono essere di considerazione e
di affetto tutte queste questi bisogni
che abbiamo e quando riusciamo a
soddisfare questi bisogni ci carichiamo
un'energia bellissima che ci rimette in
circolo e devolviamo
tra questi due mercati sono in grossa
competizione soprattutto e soprattutto
non solo ma soprattutto per due fattori
fondamentali il tempo e gli obiettivi il
tempo è chiaro abbiamo 24 ore tutti
quanti e 8 ore dormiamo 8 ore lavoriamo
ci restano torre per il mercato senza
denaro ma in realtà dobbiamo andare al
lavoro e perché non è pagato questo
andare al lavoro ma dobbiamo anche
mangiare quindi colazione pranzo cena
dobbiamo andare a fare spero insomma il
tempo nel mercato senza denaro molto
spesso drammaticamente complesso e poi
ci sono gli obiettivi più che dire che
il discorso degli obiettivi noi sappiamo
nel mercato col denaro è quello più di
fare più denaro e nel mercato senza
denaro ea realizzare i nostri sogni più
importante realizzare i nostri sogni
e importante capire che c'è ci deve
essere una priorità
questo voglio passarvi sono molto più
importanti i nostri sogni quindi noi
dobbiamo mettere al primo posto gli
obiettivi del mercato senza denaro
perché questo crea il benessere
ecco questo è dovevo dire nel 2020 e
arriviamo qui c'è telex laiche movie è
sobbalzo perché lei che movie mi dà una
possibilità di lettura ancora più
articolata
perché introduce nella sequenza
il regista al protagonista il ruolo ma
anche la scena è quello lì in un azione
ma cavolo ma noi abbiamo quindi questa
nostra vita il nostro film
del film il film la nostra vita noi
abbiamo due scene mercato col denaro il
mercato senza denaro e ci spostiamo
continuamente da una all'altra e
all'interno di queste scene abbiamo dei
diversi ruoli
il regista ad esempio è colui che ha un
messaggio da trasmettere tutto il film
giro attorno a questo messaggio che lui
vuole trasmettere ok poi c'è il
protagonista che un attore l'attore è
bravo perché aiuta aiuta il regista
trasmettere esattamente quel messaggio è
molto bravo ma attenzione il messaggio
non è dell'attore il messaggio del
regista e poi ci sono le comparse le
comparse in realtà occupano uno spazio
questo spazio
li costringe a fare quello che gli viene
detto loro fanno quello che gli viene
eletto quindi ecco che abbiamo questi
ingredienti per capire come funzionano
queste cose in faccia o riporto due mie
episodi della mia vita chiaramente uno
nel mercato col denaro l'altro il
mercato senza denaro nel mercato col
denaro mi ricordo quando ho lasciato la
piccola media azienda italiana per
andare la multinazione multinazionale
svizzera
dovevo prendere come posto quello di
vice direttore generale perché il
direttore generale di quella realtà che
era in italia della riproduzione
quel direttore generale doveva andare né
gli headquarter proprio perché facevo un
passaggio verso la svizzera e quindi io
sarei diventato direttore generale bene
dove iniziare a settembre
cosa succede che quasi fine metà fine
fine agosto
vengono mi viene comunicato dal
megadirettore generale svizzero c'è
proprio il top del top fantozziano mi
chiama il cesareo ingegnere ci sono
stati dei cambiamenti
l'azienda per cui dovete vicedirettore
generale è stata inglobata nella filiale
italiana ma lì c'è già il direttore
generale quindi sa che cosa ha senso e
non può dimenticare il fatto diventa
lenti settore generale le sarà
responsabili di stabilimento
ecco chiaramente lì nel mercato senza il
mercato col denaro la regia non era
nelle mie mani
quindi cosa ho fatto io un po così
attenzione poi non si preoccupi è perché
lo stipendio è quello che abbiamo
concordato meno male sono io ho lavorato
con queste persone abbiamo portato
l'efficienza delle aziende a un livello
molto più elevato 120 persone che hanno
trovato insieme perché mi piace far
lavorare insieme
lavora con le persone avrei saputo
insieme e siamo arrivati un punto molto
elevato tanto è vero che mi hanno anche
mia mi hanno anche ha premiato per
questa cosa qua allora il punto però era
che non ero il regista sono stato un
bravo attore allo stipendio ma non ero
il regista
per fare questa performance nello stesso
momento mi sposto il mercato senza
denaro e del mercato senza denaro aveva
a quel tempo c'era mia moglie con due
bambini
oggi sono cresciuti a mia moglie e ai
miei figli sono qui sono felicissimo che
sino a qui ve li grandi allora in quel
momento di conseguenza io uscivo la
mattina del lunedì e tornava a casa il
venerdì sera beh inutile dire che in
queste condizioni essere regista nel
mercato senza denaro era impossibile
allora cosa diceva ovvero non c'è
problema io faccio il bravo protagonista
nel mercato senza denaro ma sabato e
domenica ma non funzionava perché in
realtà se su sette giorni cinque giorni
non ci sei non sei neanche una comparsa
sei una scomparsa
ecco che mia moglie per fortuna una
moglie così abbiamo ragionato su questa
cosa e abbiamo deciso di fare un
passaggio in passaggio diverso cambiare
lavoro
avevo due posti di opportunità la prima
era quella di trovare
cercare mi metto sul mercato cerca un
lavoro che mi dia esattamente lo stesso
stipendio
l'altro invece dire no aspetta un
pochettino più importante che io torno
ogni sera a casa ma anche eventualmente
uno stipendio basso perché la prima
quella di cercare un posto che mi
dessero sostiene avrei voluto portare
via parecchio tempo uno o due anni gli
avrei persi
a questo punto abbiamo fatto la scelta
che la seconda grazie appunto a mia
moglie che mi ha supportato questa è
stato il mio biscuit ecco che capisco
gli americani e non soltanto i militari
al sun che l'italia stanno arrivando
questa questa questa tendenza io l'ho
fatta tempo fa in quel momento ho
ripreso in mano la regia del mio mercato
senza denaro io adesso con la mia
azienda vado in giro per le aziende
parlo con tantissimi manager e mi capita
di trovare dei manager che mi dicono
claudio
sai io sto male sto veramente male è
pazzesco
lunedì ho veramente i crampi allo
stomaco vorrei non venire qui e faccio
scusami che tipo di scelte puoi fare è
ma io non posso cambiare lavoro perché
sai non trovo un posto che mi dà lo
stesso stipendio
ecco io queste persone le vedo in gambia
è come se avessero fatto loro una gabbia
è la cosa incredibile che non sono
consapevoli che questa gabbia alla porta
aperta magari è stretta questa porta ma
ce l'ha aperta
bisogna fare una scelta
ecco io questa scelta l'ho fatta non
sono più nella multinazionale non
guadagno più quei soldi ma una famiglia
di cui sono estremamente orgoglioso
ho potuto fare tante cose ho scritto dei
libri per ragazzi ho fatto ho fatto la
mia azienda quindi sono diventato
regista nel mercato col denaro
addirittura è e poi ho anche se ho anche
realizzato qualche sogno
in particolare avevo un sogno quello di
essere un telex pick up ed eccomi qua
finalmente devo dire ora questo tutto
questo per dire che effettivamente a
volte noi ci troviamo i luoghi aridi
nella nostra vita e quando ci troviamo
in questi luoghi aridi dovremo fare un
po di mente locale e cercare di
comprendere quali sia il mercato su cui
veramente puntare il mercato su cui
veramente puntare il mercato senza
denaro e dobbiamo lottare lottare per
riprenderci la regia in quel mercato
credetemi siamo tutti i liberi di farlo
perché avere dei sogni e diventare il
regista per realizzarli è una cosa
estremamente appagante e vi posso
assicurare
chi può rendere anche felici grazie
[Applauso]